I think around the sort of value piece
for these candidates it's really sort of
having some form of truck records
somewhere and at least understanding the
market you're recruiting in I think it
would be incredibly challenging to take
somebody who's never done real estate
recruitment for example and put them in
a new market because they have no
understanding in terms of recruitment
real estate how they can create value
for people a couple of guys I spoke with
weren't relevant for the role I was
working on but we want to make that
introductory conversation number one
from your side because you can pick
their brains and get better knowledge on
the market and also building a warm
introduction so the next time something
does come on in six months time you can
pick the phone up to that person they
should remember you and then it makes it
a lot easier than just sort of a cold
call uh you're just trying to get the
person's interest because you've already
spoke with them